welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends this is Doug Batchelor
would you like to hear an amazing fact
back in 1982 the Alameda family lost a
beloved pen the red footed tortoise
named Manuelo mysteriously disappeared
from the home in the suburbs of Rio de
Janeiro Brazil the mystery was solved
recently when Leandro Alameda was
cleaning out a storage shed in the
process he placed an old wooden box with
a record player on the pavement for the
trash collectors to pick up then a
neighbor walking by asked you're not
throwing out the turtle as well are you
at that moment Leandro turned white and
said I just couldn't believe what I was
seen in the box with the old record
player was their long-lost tortoise
still alive after more than 30 years
Leandro sister Linea who had been given
the tortoise as a childhood pet told the
local news we are all thrilled to have
Manuel aback but no one can understand
how she managed to survive for 30 years
in a box it's just unbelievable even the
experts were stumped Jefferson Perez a
real veterinarian said that red-footed
tortoises have been known to go without
eating for two or three years in the
wild but 30 years is totally off the
charts he speculated that Manuel is
survived by licking condensation and
eating small insects that crawled into
the box being stuck in a box for 30
years sounds even worse than being
trapped in a whale for three days stay
with his friends were gonna learn more
as amazing facts brings you this edition
of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
says that's one eight hundred four six
three seventy to ninety seven now let's
join our host pastor Doug Batchelor and
our co-host pastors Jean Ross
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live one of the best possible
uses of talk radio is to talk about the
Word of God if you've got a question
about the Bible this is the program
we'll do our best to answer it together
the phone number lines are wide open
right now 800 God says 800 four six
three seven two nine seven you know
we've got a lot of friends that are out
on the road listening on satellite radio
give us a call 800 says with your Bible
questions that's 800 for six three seven
two nine seven and we'll do our best to
search the word and find some answers
together my name is Doug Batchelor my
name is John Ross good evening friends
and pastor Doug let's be in the program
with prayer dear father in heaven we
thank you once again that we have this
opportunity to study the Bible together
we ask for the Holy Spirit to come guide
our hearts our minds lead us Lord into a
clearer understanding of Scripture
phobias in Jesus name Amen
amen well pastor day opened the program
but talking about a remarkable tortoise
talked about endurance thirty years in a
box and of course as you mentioned they
think maybe it lived on eating some kind
of antal grub that found its way into
the box and termites something they're
not sure it's it's gotten everybody mr.
clay I think the story even appeared in
National Geographic because they thought
it was just you know astounding it was
the family pet they all witnessed it I
guess it had some peculiar markings on
it and
poor thing I wonder how he felt after
you know if you Turtles could talk it
free you guys forgot about me thirty
years but yeah you know it made me think
Turtles can actually and this was a
tortoise but Turtles can put themselves
a form of suspended animation they can
restrict their breathing and slow down
their metabolism
they you know bury themselves in the mud
but tortoises this has never been known
it before it made me think about you
know people always read the miracles in
the Bible and see well that could never
happen well we hear about miracles all
the time and so when it tells us that a
man could be in a fish for three days
and three nights and come out alive
you're right that is incredible that is
hard to believe and that's where it's in
the Bible it's a miracle that it
happened but I believe it happened
because Jesus said that it happened
matter of fact you can read about this
in Matthew chapter 12 Christ said what
happened to Jonah is a very important
event it's actually a sign of his
ministry if you read in Matthew 12 verse
38 some of the scribes and the Pharisees
answered and said to Jesus teacher we
want to see a sign from you but he
answered and said to them and the evil
and adulterous generation seeks after a
sign and no sign will be given to it
except the sign of the prophet Jonah for
as Jonah was three days and three nights
in the belly of the great fish so the
Son of Man will be three days and three
nights in the heart of the earth and the
men of Nineveh will rise up in the
judgment with this generation and
condemn it because they repented at the
preaching of Jonah and indeed a greater
than Jonah is here now that really must
have been something to be stuck in a
fish all that time but you know the
bigger question is what did Jesus mean
when he said the only sign given to that
generation would be the sign of Jonah he
counted it could have pointed to a
hundred Old Testament miracles he could
have said the Elijah or the water out of
the rock or something but he said Jonah
well if you look at the story of Jonah
it's very interesting that for
three days and three nights Jonah was in
the heart of the earth and some people
think that's synonymous that when Jesus
was in the tomb but it says three days
and three nights part of the earth does
not mean the tomb it's talking about
when Christ began suffering for us
Thursday night when the mob came and
arrested him Thursday night Friday night
Saturday night he was in clutches of the
devil he was a captive he suffered for
the penalty of our sins Rose Sunday
morning but even more than that after
Jonah came out of the fish the fish
burped him out on dry land he went to
Nineveh says it was a great city three
days journey and then he entered the
city half a day and he began to preach
that in 40 days it would be destroyed
well you know Jesus didn't preach
three-and-a-half days Jesus preached
three and a half years and said in 40
years
there wouldn't be one stone left on
another in the temple and I think that's
why Jesus said he was a sign Jonah was a
sign to this generation because Jesus
was there saying repent for judgment is
coming in 40 years
remember on the way to the cross he said
to the women of Jerusalem don't weep for
me weep
yourselves because the days are coming
when they'll head you in on every side
and he foretold several times that this
great judgment was coming on Jerusalem
which came exactly 40 years later now
there's a lot more about Jonah in Jesus
that you can learn of course Jesus slept
in a boat during a storm Jonah slept in
a boat during a storm and there are
other things the Bible says there was
casting Lots at the cross there's
casting Lots in the Book of Jonah well
I'm not going to tell you any more
because there's a book we want to send
you that draws the parallels between
that for chapter book called Jonah one
of that great books in the Old Testament
and the life of Jesus that will really
excite you friends and it's free the
number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven that is our free resource
phone line and you can ask for the book
called the sign of Jonah we'll be happy
to send that to anybody who calls and
asks again that number is
864-226-7222 or
actually come back and speak to the
living well we do have a website that
deals with the subject called ghost
truth comm we get that question a lot
this time of year and I was I was at a
building supply place you think you're
gonna get you know two by four and
they're selling Halloween material there
but yeah of course it's a it's the
skeletons and it's the you know the
witches and at all these kind of
ghoulish images and we get a lot of
questions about
seances and the dead during Halloween
it's supposed to be sort of a high day
for the people in my cult and they say
they're communicating with the dead but
you know not according to the Bible and
if you would like to know more about
what does the Bible say about that are
there ghosts what are these demons go to
the website ghost truth it's a very
popular site it's got Bible answers to
these issues ghost truth calm all right
a first caller for this evening is
Denise listening Toronto Denise welcome
to the program
evening thanks for calling
and your question
unrepented what they were all alone
well what you're saying if you don't
mind my
challenging your question a little bit
Denise is if they're a Christian and but
you're saying they die without repenting
yeah
oh I see what you're saying well because
you know typically a Christian is going
to repent and
when you know as soon as they're
convicted of evil it I think God is very
gracious and you know some people say
well if you know can you have no
assurance of salvation and and
does that mean that if a person has been
a Christian for years and they just make
one mistake are they going to die right
away
well it is dangerous to
sin and presume on God's grace there is
a story in the Bible of Ananias and
Sapphira who were church members but
they told a lie you know what didn't
seem like a big lie they told why some
people would call it a half-truth about
an offering they were giving and they
dropped in I don't think they're gonna
be safe because Peter said you didn't
lie to man you lied to God so it is a
dangerous thing for a Christian to feel
easy about sinning and so at the same
time God is not trying to catch us and
and allow the devil to end our lives
while we are in an unrepentant state so
we shouldn't be living in fear but at
the same time we should be you know
afraid to sin we don't want to
deliberately sin
so a person may have been a Christian
for years and the answer to that no
where's a pastor rose in the zekiel 18
it says but if the righteous man turns
from all his righteousness and does what
that which is evil he will die in his
sin so you know I don't think God is
gonna try to catch us Denise in a moment
of weakness I think Denise's line
dropped off number 4 you still there
Denise
are you there
yeah are us on our fire phone system
sometimes does that yeah by the way the
verse you're referring to there pastor
doug is ezekiel chapter 3 verse 20 yeah
ezekiel 320 righteous man turns from his
righteousness yes he will die in a lost
condition but you know if if we hang on
to the Lord he said he'll never let go
of us you know we do have a study guide
actually it's a book that I think you'll
enjoy it's called is it easier to be
saved or lost and we'll send that to you
Denise or anybody who wants to learn
more about this just give us a call on
the phone number
880 five six seven four seven and you
can ask for the book is it easier to be
saved or to be lost it's free
absolutely our next call is Carlton
listening from Huntsville Alabama
Carlton welcome to the program
yes hi thanks for your call
okay thank you and your question my
question was about unclean like pigs
vultures Gavin Jers where they created
or were they there before stand
they were yeah well I don't believe God
created new species of creatures
afterward there's no record in the Bible
all of these animals have a purpose now
of course after sin before there was
death
you know these animals probably ate
other things the Bible tells us that in
heaven the lion and the bear will eat
straw like the Ox and in heaven people
will not be carnivorous or omnivorous
will be eating it's a vegetarian diet
that was the original diet for men but
after sin the creation was warped and
that's where thorns and thistles came
out and some of the animals became
predators but I do believe that pigs and
skunks and all those things they existed
before sin but their purpose sort of
changed after sin they became scavengers
okay
yeah good question we do have a lesson
that talks about what does the Bible say
about the clean and the unclean animals
and what are some of the scientific
reasons we think that that's in there
and we'll send that to you for free it's
called God's free health plan we'll be
able to send the study guide to anybody
who calls and asks that number is 885
six seven four seven you can ask again
for the study guide called God's free
health plan we'll send that to anybody
just give us a call you know pastor take
just one additional thought on that when
you're reading the Bible account found
in Genesis where God curses the serpent
and he says you're gonna go around on
your belly my thinking is is probably
around that time that things begin to
change even in nature where for example
the lion
became a beast that needed to survive on
eating other animals prior to that they
grass or whatever else so it seems when
the curse came as a result of sin and
God cursed the serpent that also
extended to the other creatures
you know and there I think there was
another stage it got even worse and that
would be after the flood because the the
whole environment the the amount of
vegetation has bears they do eat a lot
of vegetarian right material but
and some other animals but when it's
scarce they become more carnivores and I
think after the flood when a lot of the
you know
very lush vegetation that existed before
the flood was gone I think the animals
as they begin to multiply started saying
what else is on the menu right
all right mr. Coley is Patrick listening
in Elk Grove
Patrick welcome to the program
hello hi you're on the air Patrick thank
you for calling
and your question
my question is I've been reading in the
in the book Exodus and I have a question
about
specifically in Exodus 30 38 and if
Moses says this throughout the whole
chapter he says and you will be cut off
after the people have omitted certain
sins but my question is what does he
mean by cut off what did he pacifically
mean by cut off because that could mean
that could mean a lot of things you know
that is a good question he says he that
person shall be cut off from his people
in some cases it almost sounds like it
was an execution and in other places it
sounds like it was a banishment
so I
think sometimes if they would not obey
the laws of Israel they would be
banished cut off from the people
but other times it seems like the
context have cut off his execution that
fit was a death penalty
so I've thought the exact same thing and
as I read that phrase he shall be cut
off it's you see it several times I know
pastor Ross you have any thoughts on
that yeah you know it is interesting
children of Israel almost what I God's
people and God promised them a wonderful
inheritance an inheritance in the
promised land but ultimately the
inherence of of heaven those who were
faithful to God to be cut off is almost
to be removed from the will so to speak
where you don't receive the promised
inheritance and so those who
deliberately turned away from God's law
they were cut off from the inheritance
that promised to the children of Israel
and in many cases they were banished
from the land of Israel or from the
Brethren and in some cases like pastor
Doug says they were consequences which
included death depending upon what the
crime was
yep so I don't know if that helps a
little bit Patrick I was kind of doing a
search here trying to figure out how
many times it actually says that in the
Bible and
let's see cut off from the people
she'll be cut off from yeah I know it
says it several times
numbers it also says he shall be cut off
if you sin presumptuously you'll be cut
off from the people
there again I think it went you could
you couldn't have access to the temple
any more
because that was started dealing with
the sacrifices it's a good question it's
a phrase let me see it's 39 times in the
Bible I just finally narrowed it down
yeah whoever eats leavened bread is cut
off that wouldn't be a death penalty for
eating bread that had 11 in it I think
it probably meant that you couldn't
approach the temple any more you were
separated remember when another example
would be when you were unclean like when
Miriam sins she was sent outside the
camp he was banished for seven days
mm-hmm and I think this is talking about
a banishment from the people good
question Patrick we appreciate it I
Mexico Lee's Jerry listening from
Montana generally welcome to the program
my question is this
you know or God told Moses to put the
Ten Commandment law inside the ark right
and then was it the ceremonial
instruction that they were what he was
supposed to lay alongside the Ark
yeah the ceremonial law were placed in a
compartment and I'm trying remember that
versus pastor Ross where
he gave him the Ten Commandments they
were placed in the Ark and the the
testimonies and ordinances were placed
in a pocket on the side of
it worked inside because it's really
clear the only thing in the arc it says
was the tables of stone at one point
they put in a pint of mana and they put
it in Aaron's rod but by the time kya
those other things had disappeared and
the only thing left and there was the
stones
yeah well the reason I called
so many times they try D
combine in Colossians 2:8 you know
you've heard it a hundred times but
anyway they try to use that text for an
excuse for the Sabbath yes and I
tried looking in my concordance but I
might not have looked in the right
well yeah it I'm trying remember if it's
Exodus or Deuteronomy where it says
where the the law of
commandments and ordinances placed
yeah I think Pastor Ross is looking
diligently right now there's so many
references where Moses is talking about
the ordinances they're finding that one
might take a minute but anyway it will
look that up for you I know it's there
I've read it many times and we
appreciate your question Jerry we do
have matter of fact you know it's in our
lesson I bet that converse is in our
lesson on written in stone we'll send
you a free copy of that lesson written
in stone Jerry and appreciate your
calling by the way friends that does
free up another line we get several
lines free they're a big football game
or something like what sometimes during
the Superbowl the lines get quiet and
but otherwise they're usually buzzing
you got a Bible question good chance
you'll get your question on tonight's
program give us a call 800 for six three
seven two nine seven 800 four six three
seven two nine seven brings your
question into the studio and also
tonight people often this time you're
asking questions about Halloween and you
can take a visit take a look at that
website called ghost truth calm you'll
find a lot of interesting bye
information that addresses some of the
cultural beliefs about death so if you
have a Bible question the phone line
here to the studio is eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven we're
gonna say that again so get your pen
ready here it is eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven and if you
have a Bible question this is a good
time to pick up your phone and give us a
call and get your question on tonight's
program as you mentioned at the
beginning of the program we want to
remind everybody take a look at our
website it just recently revamped called
ghost truth calm a lot of questions
about what happens when a person dies
are ghosts coming back to haunt people
well the Bible has the answer so take a
look at a ghost truth column let's
discover the reality of really what
happens and what the Bible says on this
important subject again if you have a
Bible question the phone line is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven if you don't get through right
away well stay on the phone and we'll
try to get to your call as soon as we
can you know pastor died just following
up on the previous call
talking about the law of God in the Old
Testament he find that there's different
types of law you have the ceremonial law
but then you also have the Ten
Commandment law you have laws relating
to food clean man clean food and then
also some civil law and we have a book
called feast days and Sabbath's which
kind of deals with the ceremonial law
the Ten Commandment law and the
importance of both and how we as
Christians should be late to the
ceremonial law in the various feast days
we'll be happy to send that to anybody
who calls an ass the number is 883 five
six seven four seven and you can ask for
the book called feast days and Sabbath's
again that number is 885 six seven four
seven you can ask for the book called
feast days and Sabbath's you know I
found that verse Deuteronomy 31 26 take
this book of the law and place it beside
the Ten Commandments in it was an aside
Deuteronomy 31 26 is that diverse we
were looking for I think was for Gerry
and it says that in the site of the Ark
of the Covenant that it may be a witness
again you alright dude who's lined up
next all right I think we have Rick
that's gonna come through here hi Ricky
on the air hello how are you doing good
thanks for your call well thank you very
much for having me I was curious as to
what happened to like how did like
Noah's Ark landed on we're not really
sure exactly where he landed but some
mountain in Europe right well it's near
Turkey it's yeah the mountains of Ararat
which is a whole range of mountains
okay now how did D kangaroos and the
koala bears make their way to Australia
because we know for sure to can't swim
so that's puzzling me yeah well it's a
good question the the theory and this is
believed by both Christians and
evolutionists is that there's been
tectonic plates that have shifted where
Christians and evolutionists disagree is
the speed
immediately after the flood just like a
piece of ice skimming on a thin surface
of water these plates there was a time
in the Bible it says the only thing he's
in Genesis 10 it talks about in the days
of Peleg the earth was divided and
some of the marsupials were on this
section of land that drifted off and
separated from the other continents
there's this big mammoth continent
called Pangea they they call it and it
was isolated so you've got a lot of
marsupials in Australia been there
before now they're okay there are
similarities between the marsupials
you'll find on Australia in some other
parts of the world
but whenever they're separated for
thousands of years they kind of have
what you call micro evolution they
develop unique characteristics
but virtually referring to their ease
Genesis chapter 10 verse 25 talking
about the earth being divided yep so
yeah it's the continental shift that
took place not too long after the flood
yeah they don't swim do very well do
they koalas and kangaroos
you still they're not asking too much
good ask one more question sure
what about um you know what I like like
I've read Genesis son law many times but
there's no specific
statement that says that Jesus did all
this or God is which is Jesus really in
24-hour period
like if God's been around forever would
he not have created the you know the
galaxies in the the everything that's
you know like I'm just thinking in my
own mind that he says one day is as a
thousand years therefore it's quite
possible that it took a little while to
fix it to do this because there were no
clocks and stuff
sold me I don't know if this makes any
sense at all though I could well I could
not yeah of course it tells us in the
Bible in six days the Lord made heaven
earth you're wondering if those days
were really epochs or ages and it could
have been six thousand years or six
million years but the way it's worded in
the Bible if we're gonna be consistent
in the hermeneutics and interpreting the
Bible it tells us the evening in the
morning were the first day the evening
in the morning were the second day all
the language makes it clear that it's
very tight hey we're going to take a
break we will be back in just a few
minutes friend gonna catch our breath
still not too late to give us a call 800
God says brings you to the studio with
your Bible question
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture
the Egyptians built pyramids to help
guide the spirits of their leaders Rome
sanctioned holidays to honor and appease
the spirits of their dead even the Bible
tells of a king that used a witch to
contact the spirit of a deceased prophet
today ancient folklore of spirits and
apparitions have gone from mere
superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality
scientific organisations investigate
stories of hauntings and sightings
trying to prove once and for all the
existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true
why do these stories persist
does it even matter
we invite you to look inside and find
out for yourself
visit death truth dot-com
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live
we still have a few phone lines open if
you have a Bible related question call
us at one eight hundred cents one eight
hundred four six three seventy to ninety
seven now let's join pastors Doug
Batchelor and John Ross for more Bible
answers live we're back listening
friends and for those who may have
joined us along the way this is Bible
answers why we still have a couple of
lines open that number again
804 63 72 97 and
this is a live international interactive
Bible study my name is Doug Batchelor my
name is John Ross and we gonna go to the
full lines to try and get as many calls
in this next thirty minutes as we can
again if you have a Bible related
question the phone line is eight hundred
four six three seven two ninety seven
eight hundred four six three seventy to
ninety seven a next caller is Bruce
listening in Pennsylvania Bruce welcome
to the program
thank you very much yeah thanks for Gary
yes loud and clear okay thank you hey I
I really appreciated your comments about
marriage and
how we as believers and members of a
church
are accountable in some ways for
adulteress for accepting adulteress or
you know homosexual marriages I was
wondering if you could give me a
scripture reference to other sinful
behaviors such as abortion if believers
endorse candidates that endorse
abortion are they also
held to account well we need to be very
careful when we put people into office
because to some extent you know we can
vicariously be responsible for
encouraging
bad policy and so everybody is you know
accountable for those actions there's no
scripture that mentions abortion per se
the there are verses that are pretty
clear that God considered human life to
be sacred after conception you have
everything from even when David sinned
with Bathsheba she said to David I am
with child she's in the same with a
fetus they always referred to it as a
living being and of course when John the
Baptist was in vitro with Elizabeth he
rejoiced when Mary knocked on the door
and she was pregnant with Jesus and she
said the babe I rejoiced that left
within me at your tidings and and so you
know the language in the bay in the
Bible is pretty clear that they believed
that once a person was with child
that there was something sacred about
that and you know if human life begins
what is a starting point in really the
only time that you could point to you
can't say well after this many months
and it has this many cells and it's got
five hundred cells and a you know and
this is developed you know people are
just trying to move the definition once
conception takes place there is a spark
of life and it begins to grow all
through its life before and after birth
and so
life would begin at conception which
means that terminating that life would
be serious business
so yeah of course this isn't our culture
it's in our candidates and
people need to keep be advised of what
they're voting for when they vote so it
believers
endorse or vote for
candidates that say they will promote
what God is against are they held
accountable yeah that's probably one of
several issues that are on the table I
mean there's there's a lot of you know
that of course is a very serious issue
the candidates are yeah you know I want
to be very careful not to go into any
specific party or candidate but you know
there's also the issues about the views
on marriage and
you know things that used to be sacred
to Americans it seems like a lots of
changing and
well we just need to pray Bible's pretty
clear we need to pray for our leaders
and pray for our country because it's
looking pretty frightening right now
hey I appreciate your call Bruce hope
that helps the answer your question
[Music]
people have
you know
you know what Britney your phone I don't
know if you're on a wireless sir but if
you've got a handheld I actually I think
we we may have lost you you're asking
about the spirit your phone was breaking
up with a digital breakup and I think
we've lost you you're you're asking a
question if I understand correctly about
the spirit what verses talk about the
spirit what part of man go to be with
God is this the good and the evil what
does it mean in the Bible where it says
that when a person dies they dust
returns to the earth as it was and the
spirit returns to God who gave it and
you'll you'll find that in please II ask
these 12:7 well the spirit that returns
to God is not a little ghost of you it's
the word spirit there is a Hebrew word
Roja and it means the breath it's like
God breathed into Adam and he became a
living soul and Jobe says all the while
the Spirit of God is in my nostrils
well you don't usually think of a little
spirit or ghost being in your nose it's
talking about the breath of God being in
your nostrils and so when a person dies
the power of life the breath of life
returns to God who gave it the body
returns to earth the essence of who you
are comes back to life at the
resurrection when God reunites that
essence it's like I've got a jump drive
plugged into my computer it's got all my
files on it it's absolutely useless when
it's on my jump drive when I plug it
into the computer and put it in the
right software it comes to life well
that's kind of a crude illustration but
God's got the data on who we are it's
not conscious and floating around
without a body and
when the resurrection happens God places
the essence of who we are back in our
bodies and we experience consciousness
again that's why Jesus said otherwise
you're asleep when Lazarus died Jesus
that our friend Lazarus is asleep
you know we have a study guide cold ah
the dead really dead and it deals with
this very verse and this very subject
and we'll be happy to send this to
anybody who calls and asks the number to
call he's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven you can answer the
study guide called are the dead really
dead we'll be able to send it to anybody
who calls and asks our next call is
Carol and Carol is listening in Oakland
California Carol welcome to the program
hi
evening thanks for calling thank you for
taking my call
I've been conflicted in used about
holidays and still trying to make up my
mind about
God I guess you'd say and you know kind
of look to the churches but when I see
them
celebrating Halloween parties then maybe
they have rabbits at Easter or they have
Santa at Christmas I get confused as to
is that okay to celebrate those holidays
in our and some of the secular ones well
you know there's obviously let's just
talk about the Christmas Easter first
there's no commandment to celebrate
either of those there are pagan
trappings connected with
Christmas because Jesus was very likely
born in the fall the Bible is pretty
clear on that the the date of Christmas
was picked by the church hundreds of
years after Christ in an attempt to try
to win over some of the Sun worshipers
that were in Rome and then the big
holiday was the twenty-fifth it was when
the days were the shortest in the year
and they finally got longer on I think
the shortest day in winter solstice at
least in the northern hemisphere is the
21st and the day stay about the same
length and their first noticeably longer
the twenty-fifth they always call that
the birth of the Sun and so the
Christian said look let's pick a
birthday for Jesus and try and win over
some of these Sun worshipers and you
know a lot of the the the pagan rituals
connected with Christmas I think that
Christians should avoid and if if you're
gonna do it Paul says in Romans 14 if
you're gonna regarded they regard it to
the Lord you know talk about the gift of
God's Son and so forth and even with
Easter Jesus did rise that time of year
but there's a lot of pagan Spring rights
that are connected with Easter that have
nothing to do with the Bible bunnies and
eggs it's all from you know pagan
fertility rites
but Halloween and it is really nothing
Christian about it you know it just it
comes from
you know a druid
celebration and kind of a combination of
some of the fall harvest festivals that
they had but it was always mixed with
the occult and
sacrificing to the pagan gods for their
harvest and
you know you could actually look at the
website talking about death truth or
ghost truth and there's stuff there I
don't think that the Christians should
get involved in that you know that
doesn't mean when trick-or-treaters
knock on your door if you're in the
suburbs that you supposed to open the
door and yell at them and slam the door
and say we don't believe in Halloween I
mean you could probably do something
redeeming and give them something good
but use it as a witnessing opportunity
but yeah I I want to send my kids out
trick or treating
so I don't know did that sound like a
convoluted answer Carol no no it didn't
but I just feel like I'm being what is
legalistic two people that know me if I
you know if I see those things that are
not godly in those holidays and I and I
even see churches how you're not being
realistic there's no your if your
friends think that and that's their
their issue but if you say look I've got
convictions that some of these holidays
that it's you know become commercial and
it's got pagan roots and I'm not
comfortable they ought to respect that
and that's what like again what Paul
said in Romans 14 he said if you do not
regard the day then to the Lord you
don't regard it and you should not judge
each other about these things so they
have no right
Romans 14 you can start with verse 1 I
guess first 5 is where that part begins
and Romans chapter 14 yeah it talks
about judging people regarding keeping
of days it Paul was talking about some
of the Jewish converts to Christianity
we're telling the Christians you need to
remember the Day of Atonement and
Passover and the annual Jewish feasts
and Paul said no they don't those things
were fulfilled in Christ and if you want
to go ahead if you don't don't judge
your brother so they had the same kind
of issue back then but there were
different feast days they were talking
about different things so if you were at
a family gathering and then you know
they had nothing but Santa they didn't
even really believe in God so I just
sometimes wonder why they even celebrate
Christmas because yeah
what you're asking a great question it's
a very practical question sometimes you
know I might be with family that is not
of a Christian persuasion and there's
grandkids and people there and they're
making a big deal about Santa and you
might you know just you have to know
when to have good judgment to hold your
peace and to be diplomatic you don't
have to barge out and sometimes you just
grin and bear it and all of us win with
family you have to sometimes does love
them and they don't understand I've got
a lot of unbelieving family I just went
to a wedding where there's you know
drinking and stuff going on I would
never do but this is some of my closest
family and I wanted to be there to
support the marriage so it's it's
awkward I guess we just leave it to God
to decide whether we've because I heard
a sermon the other day and it really
convicted me and I'm
trying to decide what I believe about
Jesus and guy and it talks about not
just believing in Jesus to keep from
going to hell but you really know that
you're going along the right path when
you're doing things to please him yeah
absolutely and you want to do it because
you love the Lord you know Carol you
would really instead of focusing too
much right now on how to react to the
holidays you would really be blessed by
the amazing facts Bible study course
because it just goes through the
foundations of what does it mean to be a
believer and it's free and no one's
gonna knock on your door try and sell
you makeup products you just ask for
this free Bible study course they will
send it to you and I promise you it will
change your life nobody call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and Carol just say you'd like to
sign up for the free amazing facts Bible
studies again it's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and one
more time eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven ask for the amazing
facts and Bible studies that's
absolutely free we'll send it to you in
the mail our next caller is caller Carol
listening in California Carol welcome to
the program
doing good
thank you yeah I have
questions for leg I
have
listened to three-day bien to Sabbath
the goal and you were thinking on
abortion and
my question and I may not have
understood what you said
but from what I understood if someone
has done that then
because they robbed the child of making
a decision to serve God or not
they're guilty and
forever
it can't be fixed like even if you ask
forgiveness
so well let a mother be lost forever
no not necessarily it's a sin but it's
not the unpardonable sin and I'm not
sure what program you watched but I
don't think I've ever said because you
know sometimes they show programs on
different networks i I think may have
been tape five years ago I don't know
but
my belief is that abortion is a sin a
lot of people do it and ignorance they
you know the culture acts like it's you
know just having a cavity filled and so
there are people who aren't aware of the
gravity of what's happening and God
knows that he looks on the heart and
whenever a person confesses a sin and
repent of his sin the promise is in
first John that if we confess and repent
he is faithful and just to forgive us
and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness
now that doesn't mean that that
child will suddenly now be born there
are consequences to our sins will never
change that's probably what you heard me
say but it doesn't mean that there's no
forgiveness I mean God forgave David for
adultery and murder of a friend and so
you know certainly there is
forgiveness but so I want to make sure
you understand that loud and clear you
just tell the Lord confess your sin
repent of your sin and you know God
promises he'll look upon you as you were
born again and you're a new creature
even though the child dude you can't
decide well there's all kinds of ways
that we sin where we affect other people
we cannot take back those consequences
I'll give you let me give you another
quick example from the Bible there was a
king of Judah whose name was Manasseh
and he was not a good man and he killed
the prophet Isaiah he killed several
people even made some of his children
pass through the fire which means he
offered them to pagan fire gods Molech
and others yeah just a just you know
think well that's the unpardonable sin
but he repented of his sins and God
forgave him so
you know if God can forgive people like
Manasseh
then of course there's hope but you know
it doesn't doesn't mean now that you
know there'll be cases where children
are resurrected in the new earth and be
reunited with their parents
you see what I'm saying so there's still
hope in that respect
but yeah the consequences for Earth
anyway we can't always reverse that it
thank you very much Carol I hope that
gives you a little encouragement and
that answers that question I mixed
Coley's Eve on listening in New Jersey
Yvonne welcome to the program hello how
are you doing well thank you for calling
thank you I'm calling about Revelation
chapter 17 okay and my
explanation of it and the focus being on
birth high
was is that verse talking about an
actual woman and I'm trying to
understand
alright well I'll answer the first part
of your question and then John pastor
Ross he loves Revelation I'll let him
take a stab at it
well no the woman is not a real woman
that woman this is a vision John is in
and this woman Bible tells us women
represent churches and a woman that has
a paragraph in her forehead that says
mother of harlots she is an unfaithful
Church
out of which many other churches came
keep in mind also it says those who are
saved in the last days have the seal of
God in their foreheads - and so a lot of
people have things in their foreheads in
Revelation it's all symbolic of what
they believe that's Ross do you have
anything to add you know we not only
talk about babbling in revelation 17 but
if you look at the second angels message
in Revelation chapter 14 it says Babylon
is fallen is fallen so Babylon the name
given to a woman represents a religious
institution that also has great
political influence and at the end of
time plays a rather significant role in
pulling the world together and at some
point enforcing the mark of the beast so
we do have a study guide that goes into
this in a lot more detail than we have
time to be able to cover here on the
program and we'll be happy to send
anybody the study guide called the other
woman the other woman now revelation 12
there is a woman representing God's true
church and in revelation 17 is another
woman which is called the other woman
written by the name of Babylon we'll be
able to send anyone the study guide
called the other woman just call and ask
yeah also you mentioned a verse in
Revelation 14 where it says Babylon has
fallen revelation 18 says come out of
her my people so obviously it's a symbol
of a church and God is calling his
people out of the false into the true
the number to call is 808 three five six
seven four seven and you can just ask
for the study guide called the other
woman matter of fact you can ask for two
also asked for the one called the Bride
of Christ it's Revelation chapter 12 the
other woman is revelation 17 it's the
number again to call is 808 three five
six seven four seven as for the study
guide the other woman and the Bride of
Christ I next call a is a Florence
listening in Queens New York
Florence welcome to the program
yes I'm here thank you for taking my
call I enjoy listening to the program my
question is why does Jesus refer to
himself as the Son of Man and in many of
the Bible verses that I've read yeah
that's a good question
I where is it pastor I was one of the
Gospels he says that more than any of
the others I'd forget whether it's a
Luke or John Jesus loves to refer to
himself as the Son of Man he's also
quoting Ezekiel frequently when Ezekiel
got a vision God said to him son of man
prophesy this son of man prophesy that
and Jesus loves the fact that while he
was divine he was born as a human and he
married himself to the human race by
becoming one of us so he loved to
identify I am a son of man
and just he seemed to rejoice in showing
his brotherhood with a human race he's
forever joined with the human race the
Incarnation forever put him with a human
body and
you know even in the resurrection he
appeared as a man with a glorified body
but he was still real so he enjoyed it
yeah I was just looking at the verse
here um in the Old Testament without a
doubt the book that has the phrase son
of a man more than any other is Ezekiel
it's all over the place there and then
it looks like Matthew is the book where
it appears the most followed by Luke
okay very good
hey thank you very much Florence hope
that helps answer that question a little
bit
all right my next holy is Wolford
listening from brooklyn new york Wolford
welcome to the program hi are you doing
well how are you not too bad when Mary
and Jesus went to the feast yes the
wedding feast in Cana of Galilee where
was Joseph well it seems that by the
time Jesus began his ministry
Joseph was either infirmed because he
was getting old or he had died but you
don't see Joseph's appear anywhere it
refers to him when Jesus was preaching
in Nazareth it says is this not the
carpenter's son but it doesn't say that
Joseph's alive and whenever Mary comes
to talk to Jesus with the brothers
Joseph is never there now Joseph was
older than Mary well most commentators
agree how much older we don't know but
you know Christ didn't begin his
ministry till he was 30
Jesus already had some brothers and
sisters probably from Joseph's first
wife when he was born of Mary
and
people didn't live as long back then so
I don't know you may have him either
died or he was wasn't able to get out as
much he was home
ok thank you all right Thank You Wilford
next bullies grace listening in Savannah
Tennessee grace welcome to the program
yes hello
alright thanks for calling you know
thanks for taking my call I'll try to
make it quick I know it's getting late
does the Bible have anything to say
particularly about
embryos like in human embryos yes they
look very strange when they're very
small well the Bible doesn't say much
about how they look or anything because
of course they didn't have ultrasounds
and they didn't have the microscopes or
the capability of doing internal
photography but they do say as I
mentioned to an earlier caller that when
a woman was pregnant she would say I am
with child
and even when the angel came and talked
to
Samson's mother
they told her to be very careful about
what she ate and how she acted during
the time of gestation
you know why she was incubating this
baby that was gonna be the strongest man
who ever lived so that's about all
you're gonna find in reference to a baby
being an embryo pastor Oz we got a
minute can we maybe take one more caller
Thank You grace all right we've got
Michael listening from let's see
Virginia Michael walk to the program
hi Michael Young here yeah we've got
just about 60 seconds can we do
something quick okay hey you guys did a
great job and I really appreciate what
y'all do I had gone through a divorce
and it wasn't for adultery we just after
20 years got divorced I was wondering if
the issue is Cana can someone remarry
and not be in an adulterous relationship
now are you a Christian
yes sir how about your wife
I'm sorry how about your ex-wife was she
also believer oh yes very much so and
yet you divorced through some
incompatibility issues yes well I would
say we both needed to work on our
Christianity and we've just after 21
years I was probably the least of the
believers well yeah I don't want to
treat your question like it's trite
because it's a very important question
but I have to give you a quick answer
caz a time says in Matthew that you know
the only grounds for divorce is if
there's infidelity that
you should not you don't have a right
really to remarry unless you're gonna
you know get reconciled to your wife if
we do have a book we can send you called
divorce marriage I'm and what is it
marriage divorce and remarry marriage
yes free copy call amazing facts and
we'll be happy to send that to you
Michael go to the resourceful address
god bless friends
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
amazing facts began in 1965 with a God
inspired concept hello this is Joe Cruz
on the amazing facts broadcast facts
which affect you each radio broadcast
would begin with an amazing fact from
science nature or history followed by a
Bible message that touched the hearts of
listeners from every walk of life the
program was an instant success and the
ministry soon began expanding to include
Bible lessons in 1986 amazing facts
added the medium of television to its
growing outreach efforts offering
soul-winning evangelistic messages for
viewers around the world in 1994 pastor
Doug Batchelor assumed leadership of the
ministry adding the Bible answers live
call-in radio program and new ministry
TV programs began airing on multiple
networks around the world for 50 years
the driving vision of amazing facts has
been the bold proclamation of the
everlasting gospel and with a team of
evangelists circling the globe and
thousands of men and women being trained
through the amazing facts center of
evangelism program Affco the ministry is
helping God's church see a rich harvest
of souls
amazing facts God's message our mission
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at
WWF ag0 RG and sign up for our free
Bible study course and make sure to
check out our online bookstore at AF
bookstore comm which offers thousands of
inspiring books DVDs and more to help
you get the most out of God's Word to
take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at
$887 website at amazing facts o RG did
you enjoy this program make sure to tell
your family and friends tune in next
time for more Bible answers live honest
and accurate answers to your Bible
questions
[Music]